[Música]
uma noite muito bom fazer parte de mais
uma comunidade
afinal de contas somos seres sociais e
isso desde os primórdios né homosapiens
sempre foram seres sociais e não é
porque é legal sair de galera era uma
necessidade básica de sobrevivência
a gente só sobreviveu está aqui hoje
para contar a história porque a gente
vive em bandos mas essa necessidade de
sobrevivência de segurança não é a nossa
única necessidade como homo sapiens
a gente tem algumas outras necessidades
é como afeto atenção e reconhecimento e
carinho empatia mas outra coisa que
também já sabemos a gente está hoje no
mundo super tecnológico conectado todo
mundo tem que dar conta de tudo eu
preciso ser autosuficiente
não tenho tempo fala comigo daqui a
pouco não vou responder
então nessa auto suficiência a gente foi
se fechando
a gente também foi se fechando
fisicamente
cada um no seu apartamento cada um no
seu canto ea gente foi se afastando diz
que a nossa essência nossa necessidade
básica do ser humano e eu fiz isso eu
super acreditando numa auto suficiência
serviço
então eu vou contar para vocês algumas
histórias a primeira delas é a minha
família e uma de 27 anos nessa casa
aí quando minha família resolvem 2 a dor
no coração como assim
a casa que eu passei a vida inteira aí
eu falei que ia saber sua auto
suficiente eu dou conta disso vai morar
sozinho e resolvi morar sozinho
foi ótimo a melhor coisa ter uma rotina
saí correndo na correria sair na
correria deixar uma bolsa pra trás não
tem que pensar nossa minha mãe vai
arrumar não precisava
podia ver tv hora que eu quisesse podia
não vejo a hora que quisesse mas junto
com esses prazeres de morar sozinha e
vieram também alguns desafios básicos
por exemplo que a mulher nas plantas
quando eu viajasse ou esqueceu de pegar
a toalha para o problema pior inverno em
curitiba cai a chave do chuveiro
sofrimento na certa não tem ninguém para
me salvar mantinha um desafio especial
que exibem tenebroso que chama domingo à
noite e domingo à noite o dia mundial da
pressão é o momento que todos os
docentes super sozinho principalmente
quando a gente mora sozinho
a gente não tem companhia a gente começa
a pensar em todas aquelas reflexões o
porquê da vida quem sou porque eu tô
aqui o que eu estou fazendo porque saí
da casa dos meus pais porque resolveria
essa idéia
em um desses momentos que eu sentada na
janela de uma janela do apartamento que
é do chão ao teto era o pesadelo da
minha mãe inclusive é eu adorava nessa
zona que tinha produção e coloquei
várias postagens várias fotos lindas do
pôr do sol naquela janela mas o que
essas fotos não mostravam era essa a
minha solidão de domingo à noite em um
dia nessa janela eu olhei pensei cara eu
moro num estúdio tem 16 andares neste
prédio nove apartamentos por andar
eu não sou a única passando por isso e
aí eu usei uma super tecnologia
extremamente inovadora contra a solidão
eu criei um grupo de debate zap do
prédio vizinho que divide internet de
janeiro era que eu conheci na piscina
eu conheci adicionei a menina da
lavanderia ea gente foi cada um
adicionando mais uma pessoa ea gente foi
criando essa a nossa rede ele ea nossa
comunidade e aí a gente ia junto não foi
no sábado de manhã a gente deixava a
porta aberta e chegou a cogitar em
deixar um sofá no corredor porque nem
era extensão
nossa casa a gente fez algumas festinhas
festa baiana festa de halloween e festa
de final de ano as reuniões de
condomínio gente nunca vi reunião de
condomínio mais cheia e mais divertida a
gente pediu pizza
então há sempre de tecnologia do
whatsapp foi o que me salvou naquele
momento e depois disso passado domingo à
noite sozinha era só quando já estava
bem cansado e queria ficar na minha
eu era a melhor coisa que aprendi a
lidar com esses meus momentos de solidão
e com esses momentos coletivos mas eu
sempre fui um pouquinho apaixonada por
esse bichinho chamado gente sempre me
meti o meio de redes sempre metido no
meio de comunidades
quando eu tinha 12 anos eu na verdade
entrei na cola da minha irmã tá na época
não sabia que gostava de gente de
comunidade está nesses momentos eu fui
participar de um programa de
voluntariado porque a minha irmã
participava eu vou levar junto na mesma
faz eu faço mas amigo meu saiu e eu
fiquei nesse grupo
eu conheci um monte de gente estranha
igual eu que isso não vai mudar o mundo
igual eu ea gente via problema e senti à
vontade de resolver e eu conjunto com
esses loucos a gente acreditava
inclusive que a gente poderia eliminar a
poliomielite no mundo ea luta grande ea
gente está nela e não só como reconheceu
nessas pessoas como me conhecendo mais
entendendo para os meus talentos as
minhas habilidades os meus dons o que eu
sabia fazer
normalmente a gente tudo vai para o
morumbi no mercado de trabalho de
colocar as nossas abrir em prática
eu fui pro mundo e fui descobrir como
era falar em público eu fui pro mundo e
foi descobrir faz como era gerir um
projecto desenhar um projeto eu fui pro
mundo descobrir como era trabalhar em
equipe e isso foi incrível para mim
então a gente era esse bando de louco
com várias idéias
manda brincando de fazer projeto social
e não de seus projetos sociais
uma menina pra mim falou ainda nesta
manhã o gênio da lâmpada resolução de
todo mundo na realização de todo mundo
mas os seus aí de novo né
aquela coisinha aqui é não só o
suficiente
aí resolvi fazer alguma coisa pra mim e
entrei no grupo de dança mas não era
qualquer grupo de dança é o grupo de
dança ela tinha um shortinho com a sigla
e faziam vídeos legais e postavam fotos
na internet e eu fui primeiro encontro e
fui e dedicará com uma roda
eram 50 mulheres em roda não era só um
grupo de dança era um espaço de
compartilhamento entre mulheres
nesse grupo a gente podia falar sobre o
que era ser mulher o que era ser marina
o que era ser eu
e aí eu vi a história de mais 50
mulheres e outlook conector de um jeito
que eu fui descobrindo qual era a razão
das mesmas propriedades que os meus
medos não eram só meus que tinha muita
coisa social história envolvida mas ao
mesmo tempo eu comecei a aprender a como
superar isso e é conversar com essas
outras mulheres e pedir 10 e dá idéias e
juntas a gente foi se fortalecendo
então o que era só um grupo de dança na
verdade era um grupo de mulheres que se
reconheciam e se fortalece sim a partir
das nossas vulnerabilidades quando a
gente amplia de vez a gente conseguiu se
conectar umas com as outras
o simples fato de sentar em roda é muito
poderoso
é uma ferramenta extremamente simples
você pode até usar o bastão da fala onde
cada um tem o tempo e isso vai girando e
eu usei ela em outros momentos eu
trabalhei no governo do estado
eu atendia os municípios do interior do
paraná
imagine essa pessoa com cara super
adulta séria
chegando no município representando o
governo para falar com profissionais que
trabalham há 15 anos com famílias em
alta a situação de vulnerabilidade
é difícil eles mudarem moral ouvirem de
primeira ea primeira coisa que todos
faziam que a maioria dos grupos trazia
eram as reclamações as dificuldades e
óbvio trabalhar com famílias em situação
de vulnerabilidade social e município
pequeno não é simples
e aí essa simples ferramenta de sentar
em roda conversar sobre isso
foi o que fez eles criarem entidade se
conectarem entre eles perceberem que
eles não estavam sozinhos nesse desafio
ea partir daí eles começaram a pensar em
soluções
a partir daí ele jogar fora se torna
mesmo que eu no meu município é igual
como que a gente pode resolver isso e aí
vem uma idéia de um uma idéia de outro
da mesma forma que no grupo de mulheres
a gente foi se descobrindo e esses
grupos esses momentos
como falei várias vezes eles trazem a
nossa vulnerabilidade ea gente tem medo
de mostrar o meu jeito que na janela eu
gostava só o fato do pôr do sol e não
contava que eu estava sentindo aqui
dentro
muita gente vê isso mas a partir do
momento que a gente se conecta e abre a
gente consegue acessar o próximo passo
que é o sonho eu vou trazer a última
história
no ano passado participei de um programa
chamado guerreiros sem armas
a gente aprende sete passos para
transformar um sonho de uma comunidade
em realidade
mas são sete passos do sonho é só um
deles
o primeiro é olhar a empresa está a
olhar a gente chega de olhos vendados
o objetivo é fazer a gente ter outras
percepções é entender algo além da visão
e eu cheguei naquela comunidade de olhos
fechados e eu senti a vida que eu sentia
falta na cidade ou no apartamento tinha
pessoas que andam pela rua música
tocando as crianças passavam encostava
nos barcos e eu consegui sentir a vida
daquela comunidade e quando tirei venda
por mais que o vice já que não era uma
vulnerabilidade uma favela
eu conseguia ver beleza porque eu tinha
entendido que o meu olhar tinha que
mudar que só que ela primeiro
haja aquela primeira máscara era a mesma
coisa que uma foto do instagram aqui uma
garrafa de conhecer aquela comunidade de
verdade
e aí a gente foi conversar com as
pessoas e perguntar pra elas os sonhos
depois que eu entendi as belezas você
conversa com as pessoas por trás das
belezas e aí sim você pergunta os sonhos
das pessoas então vi um cara em especial
que eu fui perguntar o sonho dele e esse
cara
a gente estava no meio da rua em uma
confusão então a gente entrou num bar e
ele falou nossa que bancos estão aqui
conversando comigo vieram perguntar do
meu sonho meu sonho segunda 6 falar de
coisa que importa é estudar é fazer
coisa boa para o mundo a gente não tem
isso eu tava indo pro bar falar de
mulher de forró
aí olhei para ele e falei isso já
percebeu que a gente tá ea gente estava
no bar mas se tornou o nosso espaço de
conversa em um espaço de troca
eu me despedindo aquele morador e aí
alguém vai me falou eu sou um homem em
uma luta contra as drogas há muito tempo
ea gente te preocupa muito com ele nessa
hora de novo aquela situação
não pensei caramba será que se
apresentar sem ele como eu sei que o
usuário de drogas ou se fala assim é que
o usuário de drogas e eu fosse falar com
ele
será que eu teria o mesmo lar mesmo
caminho a mesma atenção que eu tive eu
acho que não
do mesmo jeito que eu teria perdido a
oportunidade e tanto de conhecer essa
comunidade se eu tivesse entrado de
olhos abertos quando de conhecer o me se
eu tivesse um lado pra essa nome pra
esse esse paradigma pra esse esteriótipo
dele eu te dou portaria eu teria perdido
a oportunidade de conhecer a muriel que
foi rainha da bateria que quebrou a aula
de dança para as crianças
eu terei perdido a oportunidade de
conhecer a marlene que é uma das maiores
muito ele é uma dessas ela trabalha
a comunidade para a preservação da fauna
é na rebarba do mangue da restinga e faz
um trabalho educativo com as crianças e
teria de conhecer deixado de conhecer
anadeje a a samantha que está no
cantinho é blindado também o programa
comigo e dicá anadeje ea adedy informou
que recebeu a gente na casa dela pra
gente a dançar com ela pra cozinhar ela
a família dela no ano seguinte lá entrou
no mesmo programa que eu ela passou pelo
mesmo processo que eu a foi para outra
comunidade entrou de olhos vendados
reconheceu que tinha ali então ela era
como eu e toda essa comunidade é como eu
e durante os trabalhos durante as ações
que a gente via eu vou identificando
talentos eu falei que tem a ver o
diploma no final das contas
essas pessoas são incríveis maravilhosas
e pra mim
todo mundo é incrível até que se prove o
contrário e demora muito para provar pra
mim que alguém não é incrível e é esse o
poder transformador das comunidades
a própria comunidade cada indivíduo que
faz parte dela
cada um tem esse poder transformador
assim como vocês também
obrigada
[Aplausos]